the man accused of shooting and killing
a tow truck employee yesterday facing a
judge today police say this man
27-year-old Jaden herder ran from the
scene after pulling the trigger was
caught hours later Metro reporting it
happened just before 11 in the morning
near the arts district right around the
area of Wyoming and commerce that's
where Victoria Saha is live she tells us
how police tracked him down
when I first got here today an employee
from all in Towing told me that it was
their business where the shooting
happened that one of their employees
died but today their business was closed
off to the public
a business that's usually bustling now
quiet as employees of all in Towing
mourn their colleague jonette Dominguez
every morning I came in he was outside
and I just waved to him and said good
morning I mean I've been over to his
place also for notary work and
I'm I'm still in shock a woman who works
across the street and didn't want to be
identified says she could see from her
window the chaos unfolding Tuesday
Morning an arrest report obtained by 8
news now reveals on Tuesday 27 year old
Jay and herder walked into the business
to pick up his rent to Tesla that was
towed but there was some paperwork that
wasn't notarized this is what an
employee went to get Dominguez the
employee tells police Dominguez wouldn't
give her the car without the proper
paperwork this upset herder the report
goes on to say that is when he pulled
out his gun and shot Dominguez then ran
off it just happened so fast but the
next thing we knew all the ambulance and
all the police cars were here Dominguez
died at the hospital but as police began
to piece this together they got a call
from an attorney in Henderson saying
herder was in his office and wanted to
turn himself in he made his first court
appearance on Wednesday
I try talking to the employees inside
but they were obviously very distraught
but I am told that Dominguez was a
partner in this tow company no word yet
on when they will reopen reporting live
in downtown tonight Victoria sahab 8
News Now